I would like to introduce
today's speakers.
Larry Lagerstrom, who you'll be
hearing from later in this session,
is the Acting Director of
Academic Programs responsible for
graduate education offerings.
Today's featured presenters
are Bruce Wallace and
Reetika Grewal from Silicon Valley Bank.
Bruce Wallace is the Chief Digital Officer
of Silicon Valley Bank Financial Group.
He is responsible for
client digital banking experience and
channel delivery services along
with the sales, development, and
delivery for fee-based products
including payments, cash management,
cards, merchant services, foreign
exchange, and global treasury services.
Previously, Bruce was Silicon Valley
Bank's Chief Operations Officer,
responsible for global operations and IT.
Prior to joining Silicon Valley Bank,
Bruce spent more than 20 years in
a variety of management positions
with Wells Fargo and Company.
Reetika Grewal is the Head of Payment,
Strategy, and
Solutions at Silicon Valley Bank.
She joined the company in 2012 to lead
the Payment, Strategy, and Solutions team.
This team focuses on internal
payment strategy and development,
as well as working collaboratively
with Silicon Valley Bank clients and
partners to help deliver payment
solutions to the market.
She leads Silicon Valley Bank's
partnership with MasterCard to run
Commerce.innovated, an accelerator
program focused on helping early stage
companies innovating
across the commerce space.
Prior to Silicon Valley Bank,
Reetika was at JPMorgan Chase.
Reetika was recently awarded as one of
the most influential women in payments.
Actually, she won this honor for
the last two years.
At this time, I'd like to turn
the floor over to Bruce and Reetika.
>> Good morning, everyone, this is Bruce.
And we are excited to be here this morning
to talk about what's happening with
the Fintech revolution.
So, we're going to have some slides that
we're going to walk through as Beth had
mentioned.
We'll be more than happy to
answer questions throughout
the course of the presentation, and
actually would recommend that you
provide questions throughout the course.
So I'm going to turn it over to Reetika,
who's going to start stepping
through the presentation.
Reetika?
>> Great, good morning everyone.
So I'm going to start first with
a slide that we've received
-- some data from CB Insights,
which is an analysts firm.
-- and what is going on in this
slide is really to help illustrate
the Fintech innovation in here.
What they did was use the Wells Fargo
homepage as an example of the top half
is the consumer home page, and the bottom
half is the small business home page,
and really describe all of the different
companies that are innovating and
attacking every single segment
of banking from lending,
to banking services themselves,
to investing.
There are a slew of companies
that are going after and
truly disrupting banking
as you know it today.
On the consumer side, there's some
names that I'm sure you've heard
of in the market, right, on the lending
side, companies like SoFi and others.
As well as on the banking side,
some of the banking startups that
are trying to disrupt the way that
consumers receive just the basic
services that come along with a bank
account, companies like Moven.
There's a slew of companies focused
on the savings side: savings,
wealth management, companies like Digit
that help to automate your savings.
Companies like Betterment,
Wealthfront, etc.,
that are focused on that
wealth management space.
And then finally there's a whole world
of companies that are focused on sort
of the payments aspect from
a consumer perspective as well.
Companies like Bill.com that
help make bill payments easier,
cleaner, and
with a beautiful UI in front of it.
On the small business side
there's even more pronounced
disruption that's happening from,
again, same thing,
where pretty much every
tab of that display
from the Wells Fargo example
here is being disrupted.
You can look at, again,
banking, lending and credit,
and I'm sorry, merchant services,
insurance, all of those
things are all being disrupted again
by a wide variety of services.
Some of the more well-known
services because they've IPOed or
are out in the market really aggressively,
companies like Square that have
truly disrupted the way merchant
services are being delivered.
Giving small businesses,
extending the aperture of small businesses
that are able to accept card payments
as well as changing the way
people accept card payments.
And then on the lending side
companies like Kabbage and
OnDeck helping small businesses get
access to capital in unique ways.
Is there anything else that
you would add on this slide?
>> Just one thing I would add at the macro
level is, I think what's happened
over the past, I would say, three to five
years, with a lot of these companies is,
every single one on there
is a pure digital solution.
So I think what's happening is,
there's a lot of disruption specifically
around companies coming into the financial
services space without the traditional
infrastructure required, with a purely
digital or mobile based experience.
>> Okay, yeah, and we're going to talk
a little bit about some of the main
disruption, or some of the main drivers
that's causing this inflow of disruption.
And we will talk a little bit more
about how digital comes into play here.
So the next slide is to sort of see
the parallel that's happening in the UK.
It's a very similar trend where again,
consumer banking,
business banking is being disrupted
by a whole slew of startups.
Obviously the Brexit news is
fresh in everyone's mind,
so it'll be interesting
to see how this evolves.
But given that SVB has
an office in London,
we get a good front row seat into
seeing a lot of this as well.
And it's, again,
very similar in nature to the destruction
that's happening on the US side.
And attacking pretty much every
aspect of banking, lending,
investing, etc, that consumers and
businesses are focused on.
>> Yeah, so there were a couple questions
that I think were pretty interesting that
came up related to the first two slides.
The first one was, where is Blockchain?
So in terms of what's happening
with the percentage of startups
that are in Blockchain or
digital currencies, and
in terms of overall venture investing,
there's been approximately
a billion dollars that have
gone into Blockchain startups.
And in terms of where it stacks against
all of the other startups that Reetika had
been referencing earlier, it's probably
about the sixth or seventh largest
sector in terms of where a lot of the
investment dollars are going right now.
It' s primarily going
into the lending space.
It's going into the payment space.
And it's also going into kind of
a combination of individual finance,
consumer finance, and then also into
different types of individual investing,
in consumer investing, or
I'm sorry, business investing.
But if you look at the trajectory
around investments
in blockchain technology,
it is on a very high trajectory.
And in terms of what's happened so
far in the first half of this year,
there has been no tampering of investments
going on in Bitcoin and Blockchain.
And the second question was related
to emerging markets such as Africa,
Latin America, Asia.
I would say, again,
in terms of investment dollars,
probably about 75 to 80% of the overall
venture investment dollars for
Fintech are primarily going in
North America in the UK and EU.
I think in terms of some of the emerging
countries because they still have a very
high unbanked or underbanked population,
a lot of these startups that are in those
specific spaces are really tackling
much more simplified financial services.
I'm just trying to get basic
consumer products such as
mobile payments into the hands of
million of consumers that are unbanked.
>> Yeah, and the other thing I'll say
about that is in reference to some of
the other markets is the US and
the UK are very similar in terms
of people leveraging credit cards and
merchant services and things like that.
And in those markets, that basic
infrastructure isn't even there.
Right, so if you go to Brazil,
for example,
the maturation of credit cards is
nowhere near as deep as it is here.
So it's similar to what you were saying in
terms of leveraging alternative ways of
moving money.
>> While Reetika goes to the next slide,
we're getting a lot of great questions.
I'm doing my best to kind of synthesize
them together because there's some common
questions, so just to let everyone know.
And a few of them,
we're going to specifically
address on some future slides.
So I am watching everyone's questions,
just wanted to let you know that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and the next slide really is
meant to focus on why is the financial
services under attack so
aggressively by all these startups?
And I think it's because
financial services represent
20% of the S&P 500 Index.
And if you just look at the names of the
companies that are in the middle of this
target, they are household names
that have been in the business
of banking and providing payment for
years and years,
hundreds of years in many cases.
And I have a colleague who's from Texas,
and he always talks about Texas tea.
And the banking global financial
institution market is in the trillions,
8.5 trillion, so again, reiterating
the prize at the end of the disruption.
And this is sort of an interesting fact
from Accenture that they are estimating
that full service banks, meaning the banks
that offer sort of consumer banking and
payments and things like that similar
to like a Bank of America, JP Morgan,
Wells Fargo, etc, could lose 35% of their
market share globally to digitally and
oriented disrupters.
And sort of to Bruce's point earlier,
it is digitally that these guys
are bringing their solutions to market.
>> I would say the two other factors
that are primarily involved that we see,
with respect to a lot of
the Fintech disruption, is one is,
I think a lot of these solutions
are offering speed and simplicity.
And I think that almost everybody on the
call probably has a personal experience of
dealing with a traditional financial
institution that in terms of how long it
took to finally get a product delivered or
to get your mortgage refinanced or
whatever it is.
Many times it's kind of a long
cumbersome process to go through that.
And so a lot of the business models
that we see that are being successful in
getting traction,
they really focus on speed and
simplicity in terms of
delivering the product.
And the second one, which Reetika
referenced a little bit earlier,
but I'd just like to highlight
a little bit more, and
that is,
it's really around the user experience.
I think that a lot of the Fintech
disruptors are very focused on starting
with an experience that the consumer
of the business expects to get.
That's maybe a little bit more aligned
with what they would get from another
software company or another technology
company, as opposed to trying to kind
of just provide a better
financial services product.
Many times it's not focused on the product
because, as I think everyone would agree,
many financial services products
are very commodity based products.
There's not a lot of differentiation
around a checking account or a debit card.
However, there can be massive
differentiation in the user experience in
using the products.
And so, speed, simplicity in the user
experience are kind of the real key areas
that the innovators are focused
on in trying to get market share.
>> Yeah and that's a great transition to
sort of the macro level themes that we see
really the trends shaping
the Fintech landscape.
And so we talked a little bit about
some of the technology that's fueling
the disruption, right.
The barriers to entry for entering in and
bringing a startup to market
are significantly lower than they
have been in previous years.
Thanks to wonderful things
like the mobile devices and
the iTunes marketplace, I'm sorry,
the app store, where you
can just get your product in front of
millions of eyeballs pretty quickly.
As well as things like being able to
host your service in the Cloud without
having to invest a whole bunch of money in
infrastructure to bring
your solution to market.
And then lastly, leveraging the networks,
the social networks and
the other kinds of networks to
distribute your solution to market.
So leveraging services like Twitter and
Facebook and Medium and
all those other channels to really
distribute marketing at a very,
very low cost have made the barriers
to entry significantly lower.
And it really helps to
fuel the innovation.
There's also a big trend
around trying to remove paper.
And this is sort of along the lines
of removing friction from processes,
and shifting from paper to electronic.
The idea that checks will
leave our ecosystem is
a reality that I really
hope happens one day.
But in the interim,
the technology around remote deposit
capture has made accepting checks easier.
And people moving to a more cashless
to a card filled society is really,
is happening significantly
across business and consumer.
Businesses like electronic
payments because of the richness
of data that goes along with
transactions and reconciling data.
And removing humans from being in the
position to constantly move paper through
processes is something that businesses
have been looking for for a long time.
So this shift from paper to
electronic is pretty significant.
>> So one other comment I would make,
I'll try to synthesize four or
five questions with a common theme.
And I think the common theme is
around people understanding the value
proposition around ease of use and
simplicity and speed, but
talking a little bit
about How this works in
terms of the current products that
you use on a day-to-day basis.
And I think on a day-to-day basis,
what we're seeing with a lot
of Fintech disruptors.
Again, that's a common trend is,
they're embedding the payment experience
directly into how you do
commerce on a day-to-day basis.
And, I know Uber is a very overused
example in the innovation economy.
But, they are kind of a perfect example
how they have embedded a financial
product, which the payment experience
directly into how they use their product.
And there are many other examples with
Amazon and Apple, and many others.
Where again, I think that what we
see happening with a lot of this,
the disrupters is they're actually pushing
payments more into the background.
It's less around making the payment.
It's more around making
the payment digitalized and
embedded in with the commerce experience.
So the payment is much more of
a utility as opposed to a produce.
And really again, going back to
what we talked about earlier.
It's about the user experience, and
many of the models that
are doing a great job of, again,
elegantly embedding the financial product
into the experience that you're doing.
So you don't actually even have to
think about making the payment or
executing on the financial product.
Like another example is,
in the small business lending.
What we have seen is some Fintech
disruptors that are doing a great job of,
you actually never apply for a loan.
They just look at everything
in your accounting system.
They look at your accounts receivable.
They go ahead and qualify which
ones they will advance credit on.
And then, it's literally as simple
as pressing one button to say.
Yes, I would like to get
an advance on my receivables.
So again, what they're doing is taken
the financial product itself and taken so
much of the friction out of what you
do to kind of apply and qualify.
And use it and embed it in to kind of
your day-to-day working experience, or
your social experience.
>> Yeah, and for the last big
trend that's really helping to
shape the Fintech landscape is
the regulatory environment.
So, one thing that we've been talking
about is when the great recession
happened.
Banks sort of took a step back and
started to divert resources away
from driving innovation, and
driving new products and services,
and focus more on compliance.
Making sure that they, safety and
soundness was sort of
the big mantra of the time.
And, it always is in the world
of banks [LAUGH] but
that left open a big gap in
terms of innovation, right?
So it was a big gap that allowed for
all of the disruptors to come in is
that when banks stopped thinking
about how do we innovate.
And Bruce will say that banks are not
really good at innovating in general.
But when they completely
stopped thinking about that,
that's really when the whole
world of innovation came out.
Just the general dissatisfaction with
banks that came out of that, that crisis.
As well as the focus on
regulatory compliance, and
the world of regulation is not
easy by any chance, right?
So, the emergence of the CFPB
happened that during that time where
there's a very strong champion out
there for consumer protection.
And then there's,
in the world of payments.
So you think about things like money
transmitter rules and regulations.
It's a very complex ecosystem, and
the financial institutions
are sort of the gate in and
out of the payments network.
So, the disruption that's happening, and
the successful disruption that's happening
is in many ways in partnership with banks
helping to innovate around the front-end
experiences and the back-end experiences
while leveraging that infrastructure.
>> Yeah, so a question that just
came up very similar to what you
were talking about, Rotica is.
What are the disrupters doing
to actually streamline and
innovate the regulatory process?
>> Well, I don't know if they can
streamline the regulatory process.
But the way that we've seen
the disrupters work around,
or within the regulatory framework is
focusing on the front-end pieces, right?
So if you think about the infrastructure
of payments and ordering.
I can't help but
not think about it that way.
[LAUGH] But if you think about
the infrastructure of payments, there's
ways to get into that infrastructure,
and it typically goes through a bank.
And so the innovators that are being
successful at it are partnering
with banks to get access to that whole
world of payment's infrastructure.
And looking at their services as
thinking through compliance and
regulations and monitoring, and
all those things makes them a very
solid stable player in the ecosystem.
>> Yeah, one other thing I would add
that has been interesting to watch.
And it's related to a few other
questions folks have in here around,
kind of cost to switching.
And it sounds great to move over
to some of these other solutions.
But how frequently do I now have
to re-enroll and do all of that?
And again, I think what we see happening
here is just leveraging digital and
leveraging data that you already possess,
is a far more efficient
way to do those things.
So to Rotica's point on
the regulatory side.
There is a specific sub-sector called reg
tech of companies that are actually trying
to streamline and
automate some of the processes.
And it's really about when you
think about it from a consumer and
a business perspective.
A lot of the data that banks,
or financial services ask for,
you already have that data.
But they don't make it easy for
you to make that data portable to just
go ahead and give them what you need.
So, everyone probably has a lot of
sore fingers from having to key so
much into various online sites and
various mobile devices to provide data
that actually is already
digitalized somewhere.
Probably in your mobile device,
or in your digital wallet.
And again, I think whether
it's in the reg tech space, or
actually just some of the models
that we were talking about earlier.
I think they're doing a very effective
job of minimizing the frequency in
which you have to provide them data
that they can get through another way.
Through your consent, or through your
permission to allow you to go ahead and
provide data.
And I think that, that has a huge impact
in terms of the cost of switching.
I think that there's
a direct correlation that
the more information you have to
provide around buying a product.
Your abandonment rate, I mean there's
a lot of statistics around abandonment
rate with e-commerce shopping carts.
That, the more data and
information you have to enter the more
frequently you're going to abandon that.
I think what a lot of these
Fintech disrupters are doing
are minimizing the amount of
data that you have to provide.
So that you can quickly get to a buy and
move your business over to their
product or their platform.
>> Yeah, and I think that getting your,
from a switching perspective, and
a management perspective.
Getting your data moved over, or getting
your sort of enrollment process is one
thing, and being able to manage multiple
different services that you've got.
So, you're piecing together
sort of a banking solution,
is something else that has
changed dramatically with some
of the advances that we were talking
about in terms of technology.
So before, people would want to
concentrate all of their banking and
their financial services
need with one entity.
Because the overhead of managing all
these different relationships and
entry points was so high.
Now, you've got an app for
all your services.
There's notifications that come out.
So there's not the need
to have everything so
concentrated with one
financial institution.
You can have solutions that you
manage through one interface which
is your mobile phone.
That's making that switch easier and
sustainable.
So, I think a few questions
around how are banks
responding to all of
the disruption that's happening.
And I think that there's a wide variety of
things that are going on in the market.
But one of the things that we see a lot
of is just some of the banks setting up
their own Fintech venture capital funds
to make sure that they're looking and
partnering and making investments in
companies that they can either learn from,
be strategic partners with, etc.
So you can see here the back
from 2/1 of 2015 to 2016 there's
been a wide variety of banks that
have participated in this strategy.
Either by setting up separate funds or
just within their balance
sheet lending as well.
And Fintech Investments, last year
was an all time high of 11.4 billion.
And despite some of the easing
that's happening in funding
this year across the entire
technology sector,
Fintech is continuing to see
the levels of investment.
And it is expected to
be even higher in 2016,
primarily fueled by later
staged rounds in companies.
And we'll talk about some of those
companies in a minute that are seeing some
of those this bigger rounds coming
through to help sort of grow and
accelerate their businesses.
Is there anything else you'd add?
>> Some of the questions that
came in were related to what you
spoke on the last slide we take about.
So what are the incumbents doing?
They see a lot of new startups
coming into the space.
They're trying to basically
offer competitive products.
In addition to the investing that Rotica
spoke about a little bit earlier,
I think one of the fundamental challenges
banks are going to have to deal with right
now is how they think about their
brand in the market in the future.
And so the reality is, Fintech has
actually existed for a long time.
Because financial services buy a lot of
technology from software companies and
from hardware companies.
There's actually been a sector that's been
in existence for a long time of companies
to specifically build products and
sell them to financial services companies.
However the motto and the path is always
been we sell it to the financial services
company and then they white label it or
they rebrand it with their brand and
then they put it out in the market.
What's been the real fundamental
shift over the past three or
four years are Fintech companies that
are going directly to consumers and
directly to businesses.
And I think a lot of
financial services providers,
going back to the last slide Rotica spoke
to, recognize that there's a need for
them to properly partner differently
with some of the Fintech disruptors.
But I think that this key question of
are they going to allow their brand
to coexist?
Or are they actually going to allow
their brand to maybe be pushed into
the background and
to allow one of the disruptor's brands
to be in front of the client is a key
decision point that a lot of financial
institutions are grappling with.
>> Yeah, and they're looking at it
from a demographic-by-demographic
perspective as well, right?
So what's that number again?
70% of Millennials would rather go
to the dentist than go to the bank.
So [LAUGH] there may be
a different strategy that
you take with certain demographics
around putting a startup brand more
in the forefront versus somebody in
a later stage of their life that is more
comfortable with the bank's
brand being in front.
So we were talking about a lot of money
going into the financial services or
financial Fintech ecosystem.
And the one thing that we want to just
talk a little bit about is that most
of the value has yet to be realized.
There, obviously last year,
were some exits by OnDeck, Square,
LendingClub IPOing and we'll talk a little
bit about LendingClub in a little bit.
I think I've seen a few
questions come through on that.
But then there's this whole world of other
companies, some would call them unicorns.
In the Fintech space that were the exits,
there's not been exits and there's
a significant value to be realized.
>> Yeah, so one of the questions
that just came up that I think is
a good question related to everything we
talked about is kind of the demographics
of Fintech clients,
whether it's consumers or businesses.
And again, most of the industry
data that we look at, as
much as there's a lot of hype about it's
really the Millennials and the digital
natives that are driving a lot of
the adoption, actually we see it across.
I think that the reality is,
I'm personally a Gen-Xer,
I'm not a Millennial, but
it doesn't matter to me.
A really good digital experience is
a really good digital experience.
And if somebody can provide a product or
solution that is going to take 90% of
the friction in the time I have to spend
enrolling or utilizing that product.
It's appealing to me and
I don't think that that's very different
across the different demographics.
So in terms of what
the adoption rate has been and
what the penetration rate has been.
On the average, it is higher with
Millennials, but it's probably
not as big a chasm as people would think
with respect to Gen-X or Baby Boomers.
They're adopting a lot of the digital
products just as quickly as anyone.
And I think probably less
around financial services.
But I think the real great
use case of this is Facebook.
I think probably six or seven years
ago if you asked people who would
be using Facebook from
a demographic perspective,
everyone would think,
well, it's young children.
Actually, what you see is, it's got
tremendous adoption with the Baby Boomers.
So, I don't think financial services
tech is going to be much different.
I think as long as they can provide
a great digital experience and
remove a lot of the friction.
Probably the last comment I
would make with respect to
point on most of the value has yet
to be realized.
I think that we're still
in what I would call
an early stage of seeing how these
companies are going to be able to scale
to become very large
sustained operating models.
And it's not because none
of them have done that yet,
some of them have done that really well.
But most of these companies have just
formed over the last five to seven years,
so it's going to take some time to
see how they actually scale and
how they become very large
sustainable organizations.
>> Yeah, the other point I would make
about sort of the demographics is that
several of these companies on here,
like coupa for
example, is a B to B solution, right?
So as the world of business
professionals are seeing the technology
solutions sort of disrupting and
transforming the way that
they're able to do their work or
save time and money, etc.
Then it's going to trickle through
to the consumer side as well.
So there is also that because it's
not just a consumer only disruption.
It is on the business that there is,
it has the potential to
reach the broader populous.
The one thing,
and I've seen a few comments up there as
well on this is that the ones that have
exited sort of the OnDecks were
the Lending Clubs of the world.
It's hard to ignore the fact
that they struggled
a bit amongst the current
market condition.
And I think that there's a variety of
reasons for some of the struggles,
there's just general market
instability that's been going on.
As well as just some of
the things that have happened
with some of these
companies in particular.
>> Yeah, again, I think it's very,
very, it's very early still.
I think this chart will be interesting to
look at over the next three to five years.
And again, I would say, if you go back and
look at other areas around innovation.
You look at the early days of
when Apple became public, or
even when Facebook
became public initially.
Some of the challenges of
going from being a private
organization to a public organization.
So I think that there's not enough
data points right now to come to
a conclusive position on this.
But I do think that because of this,
and there's a broader macro
thing going on right now,
there's just less IPOs going on right now.
There's less companies
that are going public.
So I think in terms of understanding
the long-term sustainability and
market value proposition of
many of these business models.
It's probably going to take another
five to seven years before we truly
understand that.
>> Right, and so because of this,
because of the some early innovations that
are going on with
the companies that have IPOs.
It is trickling down
to the private market.
Given the position that we have
in the ecosystem, we have.
Seeing some companies sort
of pull back a little, or
have down rounds relative
to the recent fundraising
that they're doing because
of the early indication.
On these companies, that's Bruce's point,
right, it's still early days
however we are seeing it.
>> One of the other things I think
is unique about this sector, and
I know there's been a lot of
questions about regulatory type
questions around these companies.
I think that first and foremost,
if you just take a step back and look at
the venture backed start up community,
the reality is companies will fail.
[LAUGH] That's part of the innovation
ecosystem is the reality
that many start ups will not
be able to get traction.
Will not be able to move
their business model forward.
I think what's a little bit different in
the sector is because there's regulatory
element because it involves
financial transactions, there's
a different type of scrutiny around
failure in this particular industry.
I've personally spent quite a bit
of time regulators over the past
year talking a little bit about
how they are going to approach
regulating the Fintech community
differently than banks.
Because the reality is the main
goal of a regulator for
a bank is to ensure they don't fail, and
the reality is within not only Fintech.
But within the venture back start-up
community that there will be failures.
I mean that is part of the innovation
ecosystem that happened.
And in many cases actually it's
celebrated to a certain extent that fact
that failure will absolutely
drive more innovation.
If you're not seeing failure you're
probably not taking enough risk and
you're not innovating.
So I do think that's a particular area
again, the regulators are going to have to
really figure out, probably a different
type of model for this sector.
Because trying to just
overlay the bank model,
where the bank model is heavily predicated
upon, you will actually never fail.
If they overlay that model
onto to the Fintech companies,
they probably will suppress
a lot on innovation.
At least in the limited conversations
I've had with some regulators and
some government officials.
They fully recognize the need
to have a modified regulatory
model around these companies
because they are not banks.
And they shouldn't hold them to a, not
a similar standard, but they shouldn't try
to overlay the exact same regulatory model
or probably will suppress innovation.
>> Yeah, oops wrong button.
However, given some of the challenges
that some of the disruptors are seeing in
the Fintech ecosystem.
Fintech will persevere and the best
companies will continue to disrupt.
I think that,
with this flight is sort of going through
is there's companies that
are sort of in their early days.
And are sort of presenting
significantly new,
unique value propositions to the model and
are starting to gain traction.
The next traunch is where they've gotten
sort of significant traction in their
particular markets.
And then finally, with the top share or
category is really interesting and
are gaining significant strides.
One of the trends that we're
seeing which is really sort
of prevalent amongst this top tier or
this top share category is
they have entered the market
in one particular segment.
Say Sofi, for example, they started
their model with lending to MBAs,
students from the top 25
institutions in the country.
And then have taken a broad approach to
product development across
more of financial services.
So the first slide we started
with banks becoming unbundled,
and point solutions addressing
every single aspect of banking.
Now, we're seeing disruptors that started
with that approach of let me unbundle,
let me do that one thing better,
faster, more seamlessly.
And there's coming back and
rebundling some things together
in order to have a more holistic
solution to offer to the market.
So we see that pretty much in all of these
companies, that they are going back and
trying to rebundle more things together
in order to continue to drive the market.
>> Yeah,
I would say the other point to that
the most of these companies
are doing it again.
It's very consistent with
what you would see across
the innovation start up community.
And that is they try to get some
product in market as fast as
possible to ideate and learn.
And again, I think that where one of
the challenges the incumbents have,
is if you think about the model
today around product design,
product development,
introducing something into the market.
It's a very long cycle for a traditional
financial institution to do that.
A lot of them are thinking
about accelerating that cycle,
including in our organization.
But I think the model of developing,
finding a pain point, like Ratika said, or
finding a point of friction,
quickly getting a product into the market
and then doing rapid ideation on that.
And then doing horizontal
product expansion off of
that gives them an opportunity to quickly
respond to changes in the market,
quickly respond to client expectations.
And again, most of these companies on
here will be releasing product on
a weekly basis, if not on a daily basis.
Which is very unusual for a financial
services organization to do releases
that quickly of enhancements and
new features.
And I think that's a clear
point of differentiation and
advantage that they have
in the market right now.
>> So I think that's it in terms
of what we've got from a prepared
material perspective but I know
there's a bunch of questions [LAUGH].
>> A pretty intriguing question is,
will there be a point where
banks are no longer needed?
And it's something that we've
spent a lot time talking about,
less around whether or
not banks will be no longer needed.
But what could potentially
be the future role of
traditional financial institutions.
I'll start and
then I'll let Reetika weigh in here.
So how we think that this potentially is
going to evolve is, so first and foremost,
financial institutions have a lot of
incredible assets and infrastructure.
They have trillions of dollars
of federally insured deposits,
which are basically the oil for
the engine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> To do lending and to do payments, and
to provide liquidity services.
So they have an incredible asset with
respect to their balance sheets,
their infrastructure.
The fact that they are regulated, they
are trusted, they have access to a lot
of the payment clearing and settlement
systems, which are incredibly valuable.
So what we think about is kind
of the distinction between
all of the great infrastructure
services that a bank can provide and
then kind of the consumer facing products.
And, not the best analogy, but
one of the things we think
about all the time is kind of how
Apple has evolved their model.
And it's really interesting, and Apple,
either the largest or second largest,
I haven't looked today on their
market cap versus Google's, but
in terms of what they provide in
terms of an operating platform.
And I think people, they think about
their Apple device but the reality is,
they're using so many other products
that are built off of the hardware and
the operating system,
off of the Apple device.
And so I think that what we could
see evolving with some financial
institutions is them being maybe more
of an operating platform provider.
Allowing a lot of other software or
client facing technologies that,
again, can leverage their infrastructure,
can leverage their assets in
a way that they can still monetize that,
provide some very valuable services.
But get the network effect, and I'm
stealing a little of Reetika's thunder,
because the network effect is something
she talks about all the time.
Of actually having other companies that
are out there originating business for
you off of your platform or
off of your infrastructure.
So we see kind of, possibly not for every
single traditional financial institution,
but for some kind of an evolution
to a model like that.
But in terms of the broader question,
will banks need to be in existence?
Some form of an entity that can manage
federally insured deposits on behalf
of consumers and can provide some of
the major infrastructure services,
we think will be a necessity.
>> Yeah,no, I mean,
I think that you've pretty much summarized
what I was going to say as well.
But I did kind of allude to it
earlier is that companies today,
the startups today that
are successfully innovating and
successfully disrupting in the backend
are actually partnering with many banks.
And we are, that we'll work with
a start up and help them gain access
to the infrastructure that helps power the
ecosystem while they spend the time and
energy focusing on
the front-end experience.
And gaining that network
effect of reaching
a broad customer base with
their particular solutions.
So, yeah I'm very much in
agreement that I think that that
infrastructure is still going to
be very important in the future.
>> And there have been a lot
of questions about whether or
not this has been recorded and whether or
not the materials will be available.
And yes they will be available.
Correct?
Okay, the recording will be available.
The slides will not be available.
So another question that just came in,
which is pretty interesting,
is trying to summarize this.
This is kind of a long question.
But in terms of what we have found
through our own experiences is the most
valuable ways to improve
the user experience or UI.
Since a lot of this comes
down to the experience.
Well, I'll let you start with that one,
Reetika, just in terms of what we've seen
in terms of working within tech companies
and venture backed companies on how they
approach that maybe a little bit
differently than the incumbents.
>> Yeah, I mean,
I think that one thing that we see, and
I mentioned that I run the accelerator
program in conjunction with MasterCard,
called Commerce Innovated.
So we some very, very early stage
companies that come with their ideas,
and their businesses and
how to bring to market.
And one thing that we see predominantly
among those companies is, they're
all trying to solve a particular pain
point that they've experienced themselves,
from frustration that
they've got with the UI or
UX that they've been struggling with.
So they bring that sort of
personal experience and
that personal perspective to
the solutions that they bring to market.
The other thing is,
they're taking influences from
technology companies instead of banks,
so it's the,
how do I vote things up and
down in Facebook versus how
do I express preferences in
the world of banking, right?
So, they're taking cues from the ecosystem
of technology providers that they like and
pulling those together and
sort of driving unique experiences.
>> Yeah, and I would just say the last
thing is a little redundant from what I
said earlier is, they start with
customer or business expectations first.
And really, kind of the design process
starts with the experience with
the customer with the business, as opposed
to the design starting with a product.
And that's kind of a profound difference
in user experience development is really
starting with the overall end-to-end
experience that you're trying to deliver.
And to Reetika's point, most of the times
it's around solving a pain point or
eliminating friction from the process.
And then the product is
kind of built from there.
The other thing that I think
that they do very well.
The ones that do this very well have
a recognition of the necessity for
backwards compatibility.
And what I mean by that is,
a lot of these things,
a lot of these models are built
on other infrastructure.
Or they have to have access to
existing clearing networks or
existing payment networks.
And creating that level of backwards
compatibility is very important.
So again, I think they start with trying
to design a user experience first and
then insuring that there's backwards
compatibility about how that then is
engineered and
configured to work within the existing.
So again, many times it's just about
building a complete abstraction layer
between the consumer and
all of the kind of friction that
can be created around the product.
Another interesting question
that came up was around PayPal,
in terms of their role around
the Fintech revolution.
And I would say that they're
one of the pioneers [LAUGH].
So I think PayPal is unquestionably
one of the first fintech companies
that did have a consumer direct product
and a small business direct product.
And again, if you go back, and
it's been awhile, but they were
solving something very, very specific.
What was very challenging, and that was,
how could individuals exchange value
between each other if they weren't
physically with each other?
[LAUGH] And as much as we take that for
granted today,
the ease in which,
that didn't exist back then.
So the idea of,
if I was in one physical location and
Reetika was in another physical location,
and
we wanted to conduct commerce,
it was really difficult to do that.
And again combined with kind of
the birth of eBay and the idea that
there could be a digital marketplace that
people could go to to conduct commerce.
I think that absolutely was a key
aspect of helping PayPal get launched.
But they solved something that was really
big and that was how to create a digital
experience where stored value could be
exchanged between two individuals, that
not only are not physically in the same
place, but don't even know each other.
They created a trusted network where
they could between two individuals who
wanted to conduct commerce and
really kind of facilitated a way to do it
digitally that really
didn't exist prior to that.
So, they were really incredible pioneers,
and they're obviously an unbelievable
success story just in terms of, going
back to what we talked about earlier,
about can these companies build
sustainable, growing organizations.
I think PayPal has absolutely
proven to do that.
>> Yep.
>> One or two other questions?
>> There's a question in here about,
stage do you recommend a fintech
startup to approach a venture
capital of EC to raise money?
And there's a few different
answers to that question, and
I'm sure Bruce has got
some opinions as well.
But I think that today,
venture capitalists tend to look for
specific factors when they
are investing in a brand new company,
early, early, earliest stage.
And I think today there are so many
different ways to raise capital outside of
the traditional VC model based on
the level of experience that you've got,
bringing new ideas to market,
some of those alternative methods might
be a good way to get started, right.
There's angel investing,
there's crowd funding.
We talked a little bit,
Kickstarter was on one of our slides.
There's AngelList, etc.
So, there may be a point where some
of those alternative methods of
getting some seed funding in place
might be a better strategy than trying
to go straight to a VC firm to raise
money to get your product off the ground.
And then bringing in somebody
of a more strategic nature,
like a venture capitalist, to help you
when you're at an inflection point is
more of what we're seeing in the market.
For bringing new founders,
for repeat entrepreneurs,
going directly to the VC
is still happening.
>> Yeah, the last comment I would make
since we are at the top of the hour is,
I think for fintech companies in
terms of getting venture funding.
Two things that they probably have to
do that's a little different than other
venture backed tech companies is one is,
I think they have to show and
demonstrate that they've got a robust
compliance risk management and security.
And I would understrike security,
because again you're now dealing with
some element of financial transactions.
And I know there were a few questions
earlier about cyber security and
I think cyber security is important
in almost any industry, but
in this particular industry
it is at the absolute top.
And the last comment I would make is, I
think that you really need to demonstrate
that you have a client acquisition and
more importantly a client retention model.
One of the things around fintech that
again is slightly different than some
of other tech models,
is it can't be a transactional model.
It has to be a relationship model
where you're going to get sustained
continuous transactions from
the individual on your platform.
And showing that you can not do just
a single transaction with a consumer,
but you can actually have
a model that you can continue to
sell to that consumer is very important.
I think we're at the top of the hour.
>> I think so.
So again thank you Reetika and Bruce.
Very informative and enlightening and
thank you all for attending.
I hope you will come back again soon and
attend one of our other webinars.
So have a great day, wherever you
might be in the world at this point.